J'aimerais dédier cette chanson à toutes les femmes en Afrique du Sud,
ces femmes qui n'ont pas sombré pendant l'Apartheid.
Et bien sûr, je la dédie aussi à ma grand-mère,
qui je pense, a joué un rôle très important, surtout pour moi,
quand j'étais un activiste et que la police me harcelait.
Souvenez-vous du 16 juin 1976, quand les étudiants sud-africains ont boycotté
la langue afrikaner en tant que moyen d'oppression,
parce qu'on leur avait dit
qu'ils devaient tout faire en afrikaner --
la biologie, les mathématiques. Et nos dialectes ?
Les étudiants voulaient parler avec le gouvernement,
et la police a répliqué avec des balles.
Donc chaque année, le 16 juin, nous célébrons
tous ces camarades ou étudiants qui sont morts.
J'étais encore très jeune ce jour-là, j'avais peut-être 11 ans,
et j'ai commencé à poser des questions,
et c'est là que mon éducation politique a commencé.
Plus tard, j'ai rejoint l'organisation pour la jeunesse
sous la tutelle du Congrès National Africain (ANC).
En tant qu'organisateur de ces journées
de commémoration, la police nous arrêtait,
ils nous appelaient les "leaders".
Alors j'avais pris l'habitude de m'échapper de la maison
quand je savais que la police pouvait venir
vers le 9 ou 10 juin.
Et un jour, ma grand-mère a dit :
«Écoute, tu ne vas pas t'enfuir encore.
C'est chez toi, tu restes ici.»
Et en effet, la police est venue pour nous arrêter,
nous mettre en prison et nous relâcher quand ils le voudraient, après le 20.
Donc le 10 juin, ils sont arrivés, ont encerclé la maison,
et ma grand-mère a éteint toutes les lumières,
et ouvert la porte de la cuisine.
Elle leur a dit: «Vusi est là, et vous ne l'aurez pas.
J'en ai marre de vous, qui venez nous harceler,
alors que vos enfants dorment tranquillement chez vous.
Il est là, et vous ne l'aurez pas.
J'ai une casserole d'eau bouillante: le premier qui rentre, elle est pour lui.»
Et ils sont partis.
(Applaudissements)